c'est pas comme ça
une inclinaison à 30 degrés comme ça
de faire abandonner à la télévision
c'est très bien les bras
[Musique]
un geste de défi
cette deuxième intention de choquer
très souvent dans le dos
[Musique]
quelqu'un a tourné parce que c'est un
geste
osé alors c'est vraiment
surtout dans une classe surtout les
super craneurs de la place ils essaient
que c'est moi moi j'ose faire ça au prof
mais c'est très bien que c'est le prof
le voit il est
et l'idée derrière abandonneur c'est en
repliant l'avant-bras de simuler plus ou
moins
la violence d'une érection donc il y a
une idée derrière de possession
possession de son sexuelle du terme donc
de domination il y a trois sortes de
bras
vous avez le bras d'honneur un peu je
dirais un peu féminin qui est un peu
passe-partout comme ça ça c'est léger
vous avez le bras d'honneur un peu plus
vindicatif qui est plus ferme c'est à
dire pour fermer le point et ceci et
quel or le bras d'honneur très
désagréable que l'on fait que dans le
sud d'ailleurs Méditerranée et plus bas
et à ce moment-là vous prenez la main
c'est plus près de alors c'est comme
ceci c'est un geste qui est propre au
bassin méditerranéen
l'Italie Espagne Portugal France la
Grèce alors je voudrais qu'on m'explique
d'où ça vient j'aurais tendance à dire
que ça vient certainement du fin fond
des temps on pourrait trouver le lien
avec des comportements animaux au départ
quand on observe par exemple nos cousins
éloignés que sont les primates on se
rend compte qu'il y a là aussi une forme
de jeu c'est un jeu malgré tout de la
dominance sexuelle par le réflexe de du
singe qui va simuler le fait de monter
sur un congénère qui tout simplement
l'ennui
le seul chien qui est capable de faire
abandonner à la télévision
je lance souvent le bras et puis il y a
rien à faire mon éducation la bonne
éducation bourgeoise et provinciale
c'est ça de temps en temps je me dis
que ça pourrait être la réaction du
téléspectateur face à un présentateur
connu qui en plein délire en direct
[Rires]
je suis en train de gagner
[Musique]